now the prime minister has survived in a
confidence vote and he has the full
backing of the cabinet according to the
foreign secretary but some tory mps are
still calling for boris johnson to step
down after losing two crucial seats in
by-elections this week so could he still
be ousted i'm joined by conservative mp
andrew bridgen who wants to change the
rules of a no-confidence vote thanks for
joining us andrew so how likely is it
then that say the cabinet would come to
boris johnson and say you know boss
games up you need to go or the 1922
committee um changing the rules and
forcing another confidence vote
well the cabinets will come to their own
decisions uh but i mean clearly the next
lever of the conservative party needs to
have integrity courage and show
leadership and uh
i'm not seeing a lot of that from the uh
from the cabinet at the moment so the
other route is to change the rules of
the 1922 committee uh there are some
vacancies and nominations for the
executive will open next week i think
the vote will be the next the week
following
but clearly if there were enough
members of the 1922 executive minded to
change the rules the rules could be
changed and we could have a further
confidence vote on the prime minister in
less than 12 months
and you're one of those people
supporting it i don't know if you heard
the interview
with our political editor beth rigby the
prime minister said to her he'd made
mistakes he admitted he'd made mistakes
that's not enough for you he wants to
focus he said on policy
um i wrote in january
after partygate broke that the prime
minister boris johnson was an
existential threat to the future of the
conservative party and i think
that has been vindicated in the
by-election results we've seen
this week
so i think that
quite honestly the longer he's in office
the more damage he's got to do to the
country and the conservative party and
for me that's
and i think for a lot of the population
that's that's unacceptable
what do you want to see at the next
election do you want to see
boris johnson out and and who would
replace him ahead of that election
because there is much talk isn't there
andrew around any person that takes on
uh
leader of the conservative party at a
time when inflation is at an all-time
high
the cost of living is crippling many
people whoever takes over from boris
johnson indeed if someone does will have
a tough job on their hands
yes but it uh it needs to be a
conservative and we need to adopt
conservative policies of smaller
government
cost saving delivering public services
more efficiently and we need to reduce
taxation we're in a situation where
conservative governments put taxes up to
the highest level the highest tax burden
since the the second world war
i've said many times you can't tax
yourself to prosperity and uh we
shouldn't be trying
socialist policies don't work anywhere
around the world and they won't work for
a conservative government just splashing
the cash um either and we can't go on
like this we saw the chairman of the
conservative party resign after after
those elections and
he was right to do so
oliver dalton yeah sending that very
powerful letter to say he uh it couldn't
be business as usual what do you think
in your opinion
damage would boris johnson do in the
next election if he remained leader of
the conservative party
i think the prime minister's lost the
trust of a huge swathe of our electorate
um and a lot of conservative voters and
conservative voters don't have to switch
i think they love they don't love
kiyostama and the labour party they seem
completely devoid of policies to deal
with the issues the country faces
but conservative voters
can put labour in by merely stopping at
home and refusing to come out and vote
and i think that's what we saw in those
in those two to buy elections uh sadly
so
we can't have that that's that threat
hanging over the country of the labour
government when when we can avoid it
and changing the rules of the 1922
committee or even threatening to do so
was something that boris johnson did to
theresa may and that's what ultimately
uh forced her out of office and uh
what source for the goose is surely
source for the gander as well
okay uh andrew bridgen thank you very
much for joining us on sky news